les voyages forment la jeunesse lorsque
cette jeunesse et réunionnaises et
qu'elle s'envole pour mieux comprendre
d'où viennent ses racines la formation
compte double c'est leur propre histoire
qu'ils vont
découvrir
ouvriers pour préparer leur identité de
réunionnais adultes de demain pour
multiplier les regards les déplacements
et on le fait avec les partenaires les
communes les les collectivités le
conseil général en particulier ici parce
que lorsqu'un élève par quinze jours
dans un autre pays un autre lieu qu'elle
n'est pas il n'est pas habitué il
apprend
à voir ce que d'autres personnes vivent
au quotidien le conseil général finance
le séjour de six groupes de collégiens à
madagascar en bretagne au mozambique en
chine et en inde à une condition qu'il
retranscrite sur le papier leur parcours
leur ressenti leur découverte durant
leur périple ce carnet de voyage sera le
miroir de leur émotion elle paraît
déballage poil tunnel d enter à broadway
ces seize élèves et ses quatre
professeurs du collège de montgaillard
sont les premiers à se lancer dans
l'aventuré
la veille du décollage en cours de
cuisine la destination est sur toutes
les lèvres et se retrouve même dans la
marmite même si le menu du dernier repas
à la segpa et alsaciens une petite
touche de ma salle et s'est invité dans
la recette d'expédier
alors on a vous allez voir aussi
les gens goûter comme comme vous dans la
main
patrice boudreault fait partie des
quatre accompagnants l'inde c'est comme
son deuxième pays le professeur il ya
travaillé comme cuisinier il ya une
vingtaine d'années pendant ces quinze
prochains jours il souhaite que ses
élèves découvrent ce qui l'a passionné à
l'époque les échanges culinaires la
préparation d'un repas avec les écoliers
de beauce gaia est au programme du
sixième jour c'est important c'est
difficile forcément pour eux de
s'imaginer comment comment ça va être
comment ça va se passer et pourront
rencontrer des jeunes de leur âge et
c'est important pour eux c'est peut-être
la partie la plus importante du voyage
après les premiers jours intenses de
découvertes sur les rives du gant le
groupe arrive acclimater dans l'état du
bihar à bodhgaya déjà plus de 1000
kilomètres parcourus sur le territoire
indien la veille du repas fatih atik et
zayed participent aux préparatifs
la logistique doit être imparable avec
ses 250 enfants et sa cinquantaine
d'invités l'école associative de jeanne
père et à transformer leurs parlements
en pique nique géant les grains le riz
les épices se pèsent en dizaines de
kilos n'a écouté la m curcuma on trippe
abbas a les yeux qui m'a massalé
comme de thé
c'est au nom le lendemain la surprise
les packs que dans la marmite elle est
aussi dans la beauté du site dauguet
chouari célèbre pour ses grottes
bouddhiste les enfants ont fait
connaissance la veille et tout
naturellement des affinités se sont
créées
m
pendant que le groupe profite de la vue
des auteurs patrice boudreault s'est
rapproché de la cuisine éphémère au menu
tools et massala grand format mais
toutes sortes de proue des pistes halle
by halle des donc ça c'est le saas et le
serpent le cul prime vous faites ça fait
à peu près une demi heure qui fait
chauffer les oignons
le poulet dans la dans la sauce
rouler pour 303 300 personnes auteurs là
ça s'agite un petit peu il faut obliger
de se dépêcher un petit peu iad gallery
et le dal sur la table un repas deux
jours de partage avec les enfants après
lesquelles il a été bien difficile de se
dire aurevoir
des émotions fortes retranscrite à chaud
dans le carnet de voyage dès le retour à
l'hôtel la mémoire à ce tarif là pour
les enfants comme ils sont fatigués
c'est assez volatile donc tout de suite
il faut prendre des petites notes et
ensuite on prend du temps comme l'a
remis au talent on écrit un reset a fait
désirer on se souvient par contre quand
j'écris ça mais c'est là que tout le
monde pleurait
pour
les orphelinats
et
là c'était un moment précis listons
moment francs j'allais pleurer mais je
me suis fait je me suis retenue laissait
personne de l'esprit mais
parce que j'ai vécu plein de
mais pour l'heure les élèves restent des
enfants loin de leurs parents à tour de
rôle ils peuvent profiter des rares
moyens de communication fonctionnel pour
prendre des nouvelles
les d'assaut ce à quoi la demande à ma
pour marier
ni maître de trois photos compte
facebook
les kilomètres s'accumulent au compteur
et un autre temps fort du séjour se
dessine depuis le bus l'une des sept
merveilles du monde
m
c'est un magnifique laver une merveille
architecturale dont la caméra ne peut
s'approcher le mausolée de marbre
construit au xviie siècle est protégé
des prises de vue sauf exception
bollywoodienne les faits le indienne
s'est pressée à la bhl pour les 500
sasson d'amour
d'amour après une demi journée de visite
joliat ne se lasse pas de l'histoire de
shahzad et mime d'asmara elle c'était
quand est-elle morte la famille
sa femme elle est morte quand elle a mis
au monde sur quatre jeunes filles dans
la bulle anticyclonique
loi dadt sur cette rive de la rivière
yamuna loin de l'effervescence du centre
d'agra l'inde rurale a elle aussi vu sur
le taj mahal le guide en profite pour
s'attarder sur un combustible encore
utilisé en inde la galette de blues
le bronze au fleuret bout et on fait
galette comme ça les habitants des lags
il est plus admet le stockage le gall
est la nuit tombée les cultivateurs sont
toujours au travail philippe miranville
fatiha ti et silvina tente un drain de
concessions
mais elle a dit beaucoup à la facebook
n'a pas oublié le projet
les élèves commencent à le comprendre
l'inde est un pays de contrastes 10e
jours de périple direction la capitale
du rajasthan
j'ai déjà monté les contenants service
danse des ted danson pas qu'elle imagine
city 5 ans tromper mais il est basé de
retour sur la terre ferme c'est l'heure
pour les professeurs de s'accorder un
moment de détente créative mais l'heure
de la négociation n'est jamais bien loin
à quelques mètres de là un autre concert
est en bonne voie
un rêve bleu au pays des maharadjahs le
rajasthan c'est pour beaucoup la carte
postale de l'inde
les palais qui appartiennent à
l'histoire cohabite avec la modernité
des commerces dans ce bazar de jay pour
les pâtisseries traditionnelles font
face aux vendeurs de technologie
il est bon
je prends un chacun est bon
c'était
face aux vitrines de téléphones
portables les vaches rumine
imperturbable après dix jours
d'expérience en négociation quentin ne
tombe plus dans certains pièges
une autre affaire est tout de même
conclu quelques minutes plus tard
cette baffe le fait son effet il lui en
coûtera 800 roupies soit environ 5 euros
dernière achat du dimanche le jour des
cerfs-volants tant qu'il restera un peu
de lumière dans le ciel ils continueront
à tournoyer les trois quarts du séjour
sont déjà écoulés sur les marches du
palais de jay pour cette petite session
carnet de voyage permet de prendre du
recul
tu es n'est jamais allé d'un
autre côté il ya beaucoup de gens dans
la rue des voitures passent en même
temps que les gens
ne savaient même pas qu'à quelques pas
de chanter s'offrir
un recul nécessaire avant l'arrivée dans
la capitale dont l'effervescence de
délits les collégiens retrouve les
klaxons mais les rickshaws ont laissé
place aux véhicules privés de plus en
plus nombreux dans les embouteillages
arras
l'endroit où on a assigné mahatma gandhi
la frontière en
1948 il a été tué à tenir selon elle a
joué un rôle important pour leur
indépendance et surtout son fait leur
suffit de non violence pourquoi ils
s'appellent mahatma gandhi mahatma
gandhi mahatma serment
aindi si je divise l'amont et d'autant
de mar en sera des plus grandes rate
massawa des flammes l'étape est
particulièrement symbolique pour les
neuf élèves de la 4e gandhi leur classe
a été rebaptisé au moment où le projet
de voyage en inde a démarré c'est un
grand homme il n'y a pas beaucoup de
chance
c'est de cette façon que je sais qu'ils
convoitent ce soit des violences selon
il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens comme
la flamme éternelle continuera à brûler
mais pour marquer le coup le groupe a
voulu laisser une trace artistique dédié
à gandhi cette affiche créée par un
graffeur réunionnais termine son voyage
dans ce quartier de street art
la citation du chantre de la non
violence interpelle les passants
dernière photo dernière soirée en inde
après une courte nuit ultime trajet en
bus sur le territoire indien les choeurs
sont serrés à l'idée de quitter cette
terre de rencontre riche en
enseignements
une dizaine d'heures plus tard ce sont
d'autres larmes qui se mettent à pull et
celle des parents à l'arrivée à la
réunion dans leurs bagages les
collégiens ont avant tout emporter avec
eux cette leçon de vie celle de la
confrontation à une autre culture il est
à 5000 km de la réunion et pourtant si
familière des souvenirs gravés à jamais
qu'ils feront partager à leurs familles
et certains l'espèrent dans leur vie
d'adulte à leurs propres enfants